In this lesson we're going to be
talking about SWIFT collections,
which include arrays,
dictionaries, and sets.
Just as a quick refresher,
an array is an ordered list of items,
a dictionary is a collection
of key value pairs, and
a set is an unordered
list of distinct values.
Of the three, arrays are the only
collection that has a defined order.
And also the only one that
may have repeated values.
As an iOS developer you're sure to use
arrays in dictionaries on a daily basis.
You're undoubtedly already familiar
with these data structures, but
it will pay to really internalize
their Swift implementations.
For example,
when we get to the networking course
you'll be using dictionaries
a lot in parsing JSON.
We'll also briefly talk about sets.
For this module you'll want to
open up the Playground file and
titled Lesson3_Collections.
Let's start with arrays.
Arrays can be initialized in three ways.
Here's the first option.
By now you've seen these
parentheses a few times.
They represent a call
to a constructor and
init method where the word
init has been omitted.
Here I've typed array to specify the
type of the object we're initializing.
Just like you saw earlier with the light
switch class, with collections we
also need to specify the type of
the item that the collection holds.
So we type double here in
between angle brackets.
And in the end the statement will
initialize an empty array of doubles.
You actual will rarely see
that first option used.
More often you'll see shorthand
that looks like this.
Again, I'm initializing an empty array.
The square brackets let the compiler
know that it's an array, so
I don't need to type out array anymore.
And then I indicate the type,
double, between square brackets.
Like before, the parentheses at
the end signify the constructor.
And then I can add items to my
more numbers array, like this.
The third and most concise option for
initialization is to use
array literal syntax.
Here I just create a list of the
contained items, separated by commas and
enclose them in square brackets.
The same way I did to add
items to the previous array.
This array also holds
items of type double.
But as we've seen before the arrays
type can be inferred by the compiler.
It's super easy to combine these
two arrays by concatenating them
with the plus operator.
Or to be even more concise I can use
the compound assignment operator.
Notice that the compiler doesn't allow
me to add values to an array that's been
defined as a constant using LET.
If I've defined an array as a constant I
need to define a new constant in order
to concatenate the two.
An array can hold any type of object,
including custom classes.
For example,
here I'll define an array called circuit
which holds objects of type LightSwitch.
And then I'll add some light switches I
want the circuit array to keep track of.
Or I could just define the array's
components from the get-go.